ich war neulich auf youtube unterwegs
und hat von video entdeckt namen
erkämpfte die 17 youtube an ihren
frisuren und hab ich mir gedacht da ich
ja schon mal ein video hochgeladen habe
wo in youtube anhand von drei merkmale
erkannt habe und das video für euch
relativ gut ankam habe ich mir gedacht
ich mache mal also eigentlich wieder
alle das video beginnt mit eher auf das
video es hängt an und im ersten wort ist
direkten rechtschreibfehler hat man
eigentlich gar keinen bock mehr jetzt
noch weiterzumachen
erkennst du diese youtube an ihren
frisuren da der rest auf jeden fall
schon mal richtig geschrieben mit würde
ich sagen dafür gibt auf jeden fall
meinen daumen hoch an dich mit need you
know wir klicken einfach hier auch
weiter und wir sehen schon die katze
punkte für die cam das ganze fährt weg
need you now noch mal sein logo
eingeblendet und jetzt haben wir die
erste fribourg und das ich bin mir
überhaupt nicht sicher wer das sein
könnte ich habe irgendwie so ein gefühl
dass es eventuell kämpft sein könnte
weil das ein bisschen diese
geheimratsecken drin sind die haare doch
auch relativ kurz und blonden also ich
würde einfach mal kev einloggen das
heißt drückt jetzt geh mal auch
weiterhin die uhr läuft runter ein und
wir haben
[Musik]
aber weiter geht meine damen und herren
und das ist die frisur vom nächsten
youtuber ich glaube das wird habe ich
schon mal gesehen und vater einer der in
seinem geilen poor's oder irgendwie rum
fährt glaube ich ich
glaube dass ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
dies jedoch nicht für eine entscheidung
was er mit seinem geld macht es keine
kritik weil ich würde sagen dass das
thema und das system aber plötzlich im
vorfeld sondern in new york ist meine
ich wenn ich das gericht beurteilen kann
ich weiß nicht ob ich glaube dass uns
bei punkte ließ dann bekomme das heißt
bisher hab ich von zwei youtuber nein
erkannt und habe dementsprechend zwei
punkte schreibt mir auch mal in die
kommentare
wie viel ihr von den erkannten wir
können ja leider immer neuen kommentar
schreiben mit von wegen jener erkannt
ich hab server auch erkannt und
wahrscheinlich schreibt milliarde dass
die alpha ganze auch nur weitergeht mit
dem nächsten youtuber das ist ein
deftiger
ein punkt der tour einen punkt geben
also ich bin jetzt bei drei punkten wie
viele punkte eigentlich wichtiger wir
brauchen auch mal einen namen für ihn
also bisher bakker von star wars aber
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ich hab den
geschenkt bekommen und deswegen ab
schreibt mal namen für den die
kommentare und der mit den meisten likes
der wird dann ist die nächste frisur ich
bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher wer das
irgendwie sein könnte sind zu haare mit
so braune haare mit seinem leichten
rotstich drin
ich weiß nicht öffentlich ein typischer
akkurat street habe ich glaube hat nicht
der rote haare ich kann das gerade
überhaupt nicht einschätzen einfach
april red ich bin mir wirklich nicht
sicher und es ist fair kann
ich glaube davon dafür wirklich drei
punkte bekommen hätte weil er nicht so
bekannt ist also ich wusste nicht mehr
wer kann es ich werde auch nie
draufgekommen wieder das ist nicht
negativ gemeint aber ich weiß nicht wie
ein kanal heißt ich weiß dass viele
kontertore rät deswegen ich konnte es
weiter nicht erraten ich weiß nicht was
das hingekriegt alles kleid fängt ja
schon an mich zu beleidigen verkam drei
punkte haben wir es leider nicht
mitnehmen können
wie da bin ich da bin ich beim lukas
mutiger da was
[Musik]
du denkst du bist ganz lustig
bei die vier punkten bin ich jetzt
gerade zu beginn hatte ich falsch
dieser hatte ich richtig habe ich zwei
punkte bekommt nämlich ein punkt
bekommen bis 3 ich bin jetzt gerade bei
fünf punkten und den würde sagen immer
direkt weiterhin mit nächsten youtuber
und war ist doch gott das ist so fucking
schwierig
jonas huber drückt weiter damit er zudem
das war echt schwer also im vergleich
mit jonas hätte ein bisschen längere
haare letzter zeit arbeitete das sieht
schon auch ähnlich aus mit den haaren
und von haarfarbe aber ich bleibe leider
bei fünf punkten müsste bevor wir jetzt
gleich weitermachen mit dem nächsten
youtuber ich habe eine ganz kurze frage
an euch ihr zuschauer meine community
die kennt der firma hier vielleicht noch
nicht nur langweilig hier drin er bleibt
jetzt nur woche oder hören videos
aufnehmen aber ich bin halt schon dabei
das ganze irgendwie vernünftig
einzurichten seit einem monat oder zwei
monaten und naja ihr wisst schon ich bin
noch nicht so weit gekommen die ich für
euch mal ein bisschen hero mit da fährt
ja einfach runter die richtige kultur
geld ich euch noch geben wenn das ganze
dann wirklich fertig jetzt beim aufnahme
zimmer aber so wie das gerade autos ich
hab da die tür hiervon regal mit allen
uni sachen drin und einem möglichen
kabel und krems kam da ist der rookie
von social bakker von dauer dahinter ist
pflanzen und
eine lampe und jetzt kommen wir mit
dieser band hier hat die kammer gerade
verstehen ich hoffe das stört euch nicht
und weiß das hier mein altes bett aus
meiner alten wohnung und an diese band
ihr wollt ihr eigentlich einen fetten
happy dran kleben weil ich keinen bock
hat auf die plastik schauen da hätte
auch nicht so hygienisch und der mittel
dann irgendein anderer zeit weil
dahinter dass mein bart und wegen
feuchtigkeit und blablabla ich hatte die
idee weil es auch für mich am
günstigsten ist sag ich mal einfach die
wand vollsten machen mit luca ketten
also quasi so nebeneinander und an ihren
sohn überall diese kisten an der wand
die frage ist nur bevor ich ihm viel
selber irgendwie gebaut gerechnet 50
krippen außenminister vw selber zu mir
nach hause versender
habt ihr eine andere idee also viele von
euch sind ja wirklich echt begabter für
innenarchitektur angeht und so weiter
und ich halt schon bei sehr vielen
bildern gesehen die mir auch bei info
importiert und oder den teilweise zimmer
echt night out wenn ihr also idee hat
mich vielleicht an die wand hier machen
könnte vielleicht sogar eine tapete oder
irgendwas muss ich aber den schall
schlucken seien ich meinen das geht hier
auch so irgendwie klar weder allerdings
eine idee haben sollte dann bin ich euch
sehr verbunden hat einfach mal und in
die kommentare schreibt also durch die
dann quasi mitbestimmen was ihr in die
hütte immer passieren nicht machen
werden ich mal weiter hier der nächste
youtube wieder hier ich glaube das ist
quatsch ich bin mir aber noch nicht so
ganz sicher auch mein gott meine fresse
ich nach capri sie also ich meine hat er
diese bilder nahezu überall ins profil
bild meine ich deswegen auch nur einen
punkt
ich habe jetzt gerade bei sechs punkten
und wenn man direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten der nächste youtuber der jetzt
eingeblendet wird diese frisur ich
glaube das ist genauso aus wie das
ziemlich nach der kirche übertragen kfw
oder miguel pablo nicht entscheidend
müssen halt hattrick oder
deswegen ich glaube aber ich glaube
deswegen weil die haare nach hinten
hätte relativ wenig volumen drin ich
glaube dafür könnte schon wirklichkeit
trick sein und den
[Musik]
eine last und richtig wird
die frisur von seinem hund hätte ich
erkannt dass man noch immer bei sechs
punkten wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten youtuber und fahrten diese
frisur ich glaube dass es im rat
allerdings bin ich mir auch nicht sicher
weil ich nicht weiß wie alt diese videos
26.8 2016 dabei wie es könnte wirklich
emrah sein 2 1 und wir haben im rat will
drei punkte haben wir dafür bekommen
dass ich relativ nah das heißt ich bin
jetzt 63 sind sie möchte den bürgern den
kopf frei toren 19 bin doch nicht immer
wird ausgeblendet wir haben ihn ja schon
als nahezu letzte figur heute also was
wir hier auch wieder wenigsten die
einfärbung mit drin und ihren die
geheimratsecken hören wissen wer hat
sonne friese ich kann mich gerade nicht
entscheiden zwischen jonas yukon weil
das video vom 26.08 möglich dass jona
für eine frisur hatte ob er das nicht
längere frisur hat oder nicht oder
andere von ape crime
ich würde ich bin ich weil ich glaube
jonas hat hellere haare deswegen sage
ich einfach mal andrehen bei 1 und wir
haben andere prime 1 punkt okay chillig
gibt mir vielleicht gleich null punkte
dafür das heißt ich bin jetzt bei 10
punkten rang vor watching schreibt er
hier und das zehn punkte bekommen
wow
auch
also
ich hab' ich hab die ahnung von youtube
dieser punkt hattest du da hinten
das war ziel von video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe dass ganz gegen die
gefallen getan hat las man leicht das
haben wir mit jedem von euch vier
milliarden pizzen geben hier findet hier
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
hier könnte meinen kanal abonnieren die
findet dort auch mein job eingeblendet
wo ihr könnt also die wahl und hiergegen
anderes video verlinkt schreibt meine
kommentare wie weitergekommen weil wir
punkte erwartet